okay well for people who are joining
this livestream this is a design
discussion about geometry functionality
a molten language and it's one of a
series of discussions it's been a while
since we had the last one on this
particular topic
okay so should I start from this
notebook yes maybe maybe there's a
little bit of introduction so we made
actually quite a few pokers I think as
well with make as well in the design
side some things have to trend quite a
bit based on really tiring many examples
and having various people tying it out
how it works okay so should I load a
bunch of stuff or is this notice two
things even it is to code says at the
top is that going to okay fine it's not
every single work there's a set of
working examples at the bottom okay why
don't we just go to something big that
works so you've got some idea of what's
going on or tell me how to get started
the the very first example should work
so if you click open that represent it
seemed all right to the specified
coordinates the one below that right so
if you if you shift in earth and it
should draw it again okay alright so
this is so let me just try to understand
this this is a triangle with explicit
coordinates ABC how does it manage to
label this I don't know Stan how does it
know how to label any of the stuff oh I
see this is just Dave this is
essentially like a geometric block where
it's saying this is the payload and here
are a bunch of values those are points
and that's a scalar value is that
correct
yep right um okay so here this
presumably I don't know why we have a
semicolon at the end because I want to
see what it does there's nothing okay
so this do I visualize that all right so
this represents the scene if you if you
use find geometric scene instance ian is
that the new name yes that is an
incredibly long name well find geometric
scene instance so that will
automatically find coordinates that were
coordinates and values that work for
that and so if some of these things are
propositions and some of them are
objects exactly the objects basically
have an empty seat there exists around
to make it a proposition okay so there
exists a triangle such that the
predicate circle through this is true
and oh is the midpoint of that line
right no why would I draw so when I draw
a predicate I am I see I'm drawing an
instance of that predicate being true
but why I mean don't you circus who as a
predicate use it as another primitive
visit side condition attached I not
quite this who is still the circle it
sounds like a constructor Stephen right
you know because that can always be done
presumably all right so each time I see
what you're saying so a circle through
so in principle we could have that be
part of the standard computational
geometry world just like triangle as a
part of the so for complete ABC it would
able a to a to a visible should be like
an sss triangle excellent number of
these like circumcircle yeah I get it I
get this right I mean we've also talked
about things like line through right we
so use that what's good I said we we
still in this project we're still using
line through pretty heavily to doing
what well so well as a player
- so for the existing line does not
specify that it has to be a straight
line segment so we use line through if
we want to say points ABCD to all be on
a straight line in that order I see what
does that even exist unless they're
collinear no that's the whole point
that's but that is making the statement
that they are collinear Roger right so
in this in this project since we're
starting out with these abstract
symbolic points they don't have
coordinates attached we can say circle
through you know ABCD you know in
general four points so necessarily line
a circle but if we say circle through of
ABCD instead of geometric seen then
we're saying these points are going to
lie on the circle and we're going to
draw that circle right so I want to
clarify the line through is like it will
return a line in the concrete case and
its design orient a line which is
correct okay and we are and we also have
infinite line through for the infinite
line case it's not so much that it is a
proposition but it's that our solvers
are solving for points that satisfy all
the constraints but then also that all
of the regions are valid and line
through is only a valid region if okay
so that thing is perpendicular yeah this
this code will not work here so but but
what I would normally do is I would say
find geometric scene instance right so
if you wanted so if you wanted those
explicit coordinates you see below you
could do find geometric coordinates on
that scene and it would just return
coordinates like the one you see okay
but if I take out the coordinates here
we'll find geometric scene instance do
something useful here or not yes it
fills in the coordinates and so if I
take out the coordinate blocks you'll
have to take out the they're the
conjectures of
the bottom you would have to so I got a
story is that correct
this example has three arguments the
first one is a list of rules second ones
list I posses the last argument is list
of conjectures upon list that list of
conjectures is what we don't have
implemented yet all right so I
understand so what you're saying is this
is like find find equational proof in
the sense that it has first a set of
axioms effectively which are these
things and then a set of propositions
potentially gets up divided in two
groups one that we find and one day the
user gives okay okay okay so okay so I
understand so this is all right what
what do I look at next I think I
understand this this thing here right so
Ian maybe go over kind of what this
first section is in terms of talking
about so Stephen you asked what what
does finding metric seen instance to
that's useful if you can have just list
a bco without the rules and what fine
geometric scene instance it's supposed
to do is to fit is to turn those into
rules and if there are rules then that's
supposed to auto format as it so fine so
then so then what I would do here is I
would take this I would just say ABC oh
here okay and then I would say so that
just becomes that's just a symbolic
thing great and then I say find then I
do that whole wide you mean
while we okay let me know sort of okay
so triangle ABC triangle ABC yes
why does it choose that ordering of a
triangle let's come back to the subject
later there's all section in the
notebook on this subject
well sorry Roger did you choose a
definite ordering for your triangles you
must or they are always counterclockwise
here they're the sinjar I think it tends
to to go counterclockwise but it doesn't
have to be counterclockwise
okay all right okay now I'm in a goose
you can specify whatever order they want
that's right if you actually if you put
in if you wrap clockwise around triangle
it should come up clockwise okay Charles
won't like that because because
technically polygons on oriented points
let's not worry about that yes yes okay
so this is very very cool so this is
then making this is I get it so this is
a rendering of that particular scene
statement right okay and we can from
this rendering or directly you can get
coordinates to put in you know in July
geometric geometric coordinates yes then
I will get a list of rules presumably we
have to put in the the scene that the
graphic because like in the in the
future defined what you get out is trust
the format version it is still a
geometric scene but that's not yet
implemented I say so in the future this
will simply be the I mean in other words
there are two things which are both
useful namely the symbolic
representation and the actual visual and
so you know one could imagine even
something like a show that I mean no I'm
thinking I did as the first little
off-road geometric scene is the total
centerpiece of it and as much as
the object is a dramatic scene that
formats like a each nicely formats but
then we you can apply string arguments
like a fakes or also things to get the
things out that you might want but skill
this is a useful thing to be able to see
here yeah that's what I'm saying I
understand but so but by default with
that format as a picture or that format
by default as that's symbolic
representation its formats as a picture
when you have coordinates specified I
see automatically what's that
it doesn't search the coordinates
automatically yes that sounds good okay
let me understand this
okay so what is this creature so
basically in this particular scene you
do not specify a radius for the for the
circle so for circle three you have the
three points on the circle in the center
so it comes up with its own unique name
for the radius and right now it's kind
of ugly for debugging purposes but the
the graphics primitives that it that it
generates requires a radius so it just
comes up with this name for the radius
out of whole cloth and then finds find
the value so that value could be any
value from you know it could be ten mega
parsecs or something
no it's constrained because of ANC no
but it's a constraint once you've got an
A and C but the problem is that that
this statement here could be a triangle
apart from problems of you know
space-time curvature it could be a
triangle you know rendered across the
galaxy no but it says circle circle
through ABC I know that but ABC the
point that I'm making is ABC here right
ma are just abstract points they could
be on the other side of the gallon
that's what you mean sure absolutely
right so there's nothing that gives a
scale size here no I mean arguably fine
geometric coordinates should be given a
bounding box in which the thing should
operate
optionally I agree also one issue is we
actually if the user wants to put in
explicit coordinates we allow that so if
they want to be I get it I get it
perfect sense what I'm saying is nothing
sets the scale size from a micron to a
you know to a million miles but there
are only two possibilities these are
basically the user sets at least two
points so that we have a natural scale
or we search in the scale of ten to the
zero no I agree the default should be a
scale of order one yeah I agree
completely but I think it might be
useful to imagine you know essentially a
plot range like thing that says okay
make this be something that as much as
possible fills the minus one to one box
or something minor point I think that
might be useful for I don't know yet but
okay
let me try to understand the generated
object here because this is you know
like when we say generate conditions or
something in a in an integrate it's the
same type of it's more like turn away
the power middles okay it could be
conditions to be expressed in user
variables right fair enough but so what
is what's an example of a generated
parameter how do we do that normally we
say what the head of the object is
understand there's no it doesn't even
mention generated parameters and these
basic examples because there's no basic
but but we should these examples I think
that's a Roger issue I mean these
examples where the basic examples on the
page four generated parameters should
surely have something about generated
parameters in the basic examples but
there is obviously generated problem
it's just that it uses the default in 30
I know that but so the very first thing
here should be named the generated
parameter alpha I think
after this these show this one and then
you say name it alpha agree okay okay so
here we're just giving a head and it's
it's giving numbers so now what is the
jet what is the form of generator
parameter in the series probably do the
same here right where it's simply called
generated parameters and then well does
it want to be a named parameter where
you know that it's a radius or does it
just want to be a generated parameter
you know C sub one or something if you
wanted to name it you could have named
it in from the beginning I I agree I
only have it this way because it's I'm
the one who wrote the code mid-flight
he's giving the bug when it's very
explicit yeah I mean I think there's an
argument that are generated parameter
like a missing should be able to have
certain metadata in it does is it
argument I do Utley and maybe we want
even a notion of you know generated
parameter I don't know if this makes
sense that formats in a certain way but
that you know contains its metadata and
even generated parameters could
conceivably defaults to some kind of
generator parameter thing I think
they'll be nice to be able to take the
thing apart and see something about
where it came from so do you mean
something like trying to differentiate
if something is a coordinate or radius
or length on angle yeah right show me
just like missing would give you know
not available or something like that it
would just say generate a parameter
radius comma one or something now I
don't know about the comma one because I
would even argue that we might be better
off with you you IDs because that way we
you know there's no possibility of a of
a or you're better off this no no no I
mean in these Otacon if you're gonna
overload it here if it's hidden I think
you your IDs are fine but could you
imagine your differential equation
coming up with c4 ECDC
yes - 5 0 B ok Roger Roger no need to
say there no I mean my question is is it
important that these things be distinct
in devious in a scene basically if you
have two circles you need to know which
radius belongs to which circle right so
there could be two possibilities one is
do you ever take it as input and combine
two of them where there's going to be
name clashes it's they are default to no
exercise in high school books where you
make first two constructions and then
somehow you did non-trivial together
okay well I'm not counting matters
definitive but I do think that in the
case of differential equations the fact
that this is C sub one and there's
another C sub one could get you in
trouble and you'll be better off I mean
the issue Roger
yes but there's a TV that's also a
danger well if you have a different
differential equation I see a point but
if it's same differential equation then
you get different C's that's also good
yeah actually these solvers work
recursively all of them and so they
might in fact get some of that as input
and they manage that what I'm saying
okay but what about what if they have to
make sure that a new parameter is
distinct from the existing ones okay let
me make a crazy suggestion what if the
thing is a hash of the differential
equation if the parameter is somehow I
mean maybe you can even just give the
differential equation there as part of
the generated parameter so that it knows
that this is you know for that
particular differential equation but
then you would first have to bring them
in normal forms the same and I
understand it's undecidable probably
where the two differential equations are
equivalent I am not sure what you're
talking about the problem is that you
the different parameters need to be
different I understand that Roger I
understand I understand what I'm saying
is and I don't know what hash has to do
with that okay so what I'm saying is
maybe a technique to decide where the
two things are easy no no no no order to
say no no you're not understanding what
I'm saying is you solve a particular
differential equation it generates the
c1 or c2
yes okay you solve the same differential
equation again generates the c1 and c2
you are saying you want those c 1 and c
2 to be the same every time you solve
the same differential equation but if
you solve a different differential
equation the the constants you want for
that different solution should
presumably be different you know it
would be nice if they were different
variables they're different symbolic
constructs they gave us this simply
example you saw some complicated
differential equation recursively to
some serious expansion at each order
like a circular you want to get second
that terms out of some jealousy
mechanics problem so you all want almost
solve more complicated differential
equation at each point you have to fit
the parameters see disease so you can
trust easy pediment give me all season
then I figure them out so you have one
more step figuring out what our
80-degree parameters
okay well listen I don't let's keep
going with the geometry thing I just
want to you know come back to this
question but here's a scenario that's
come up with with respect to potential
use cases I don't think it's fully
sorted out but but for instance if you
have something that has parameter in it
like that first example you on your
right side there or second let's say you
want to plot it now you have parameters
yes and so you want to set them to
values should that be automatable in
some sense and what are what are what
are nice sort of default values right
clearly in this case zero it might be a
good default value if its multiplicative
that's disastrous it's a very
interesting point and that's very
similar to the fine geometric seen
instance right and it's basically a fine
parameter instance that a fair
statement I mean is it obvious from the
output if you say find parameter
instance you know you want a generic but
generic values of the parameters somehow
like for example here if you say fine
parameter instance you can read the fact
that C sub one isn't is an integer right
I mean there's a function called find
instance yeah which I could presumably
run on this thing so I write it to take
this that changed it had to be fine
instance it will give you an instance no
I understand that but if I don't know no
no back up change is to find instance
why can't I just do this well you can
but it's okay great and but run fine
instance to begin with don't make your
life so damn complicated no but that
will give me an instance of X I was
trying to attend what you wanted no I
was trying to get an instance of one
I see an even stranger with your problem
hearing him yes so you need to specify
all the variables that are there so you
specify c1 and the X and you will get an
instance for both okay nice nice
so that's solving so that is in fact
doing what we talked about what Roger
was saying we might like to do which is
to be able to plot this thing for it
right but but but your life will be even
easier if you you started with fine
instance I'm saying you just made your
life come more complicated well fair
enough but I mean just a minute so
you're saying if I just say that fine
there you go yeah okay well okay depend
on what I want okay let's keep going
here okay I don't know what happened
with this so this this isn't implemented
yet so basically a lot of this first
section are kind of parallel proposals
for how we should format geometric
scenes so you shouldn't really evaluate
anything until we get to the very end of
the note part okay all right so I had I
had faked output for that that got
broken somehow but the idea was since
each point had a list of several
coordinates for it that you would get
like a tab view you could look at
several I think that's funky trace I I
reserve judgment on whether that makes
any sense I mean I think the list
ability first of all I wouldn't
necessarily do the list ability that way
round and what would you do if there
were an unequal number of coordinate
choices for each point fail
spectacularly yeah but I mean why set it
up that way because you could have
something where where you naturally have
it so that you can I mean when if you
were to generate this it will be more
natural I would think to generate it as
a you know that the code that would
generate multiple instances would be
more likely to generate a list a goes to
blobby goes to blow a C goes to blah
you know multiple times the thoughts
post rules yes that's what I'm saying
there's make sense to make more sense to
me yeah um now I assume that I can
replace these symbols by strings and
nothing will break all right correct
okay okay all right let's take a look at
this guy okay so there's a bit fancier
now we come in some other philosophical
points all right okay so the question
here you pointed out that we were mixing
primitives and propositions yes so one
suggestion is what we should split them
up into two different arguments and
there's sections discussing the pros and
cons of that okay but but Michael was
saying there's an existential
you know thing here you can yeah you can
view that as the statement that that is
a valid triangle or that is a valid
circle through okay all right all right
so the question is what what are you
asking so what the heck is this I see
that's that's a rendering primitive
so you could say style of circle through
that's one of the things to be disgusted
right I know they're kind of
off-the-wall thing is continuing that so
that if you say you wanted a regular
polygon that you could you could you
list regular comma polygons of a DC the
Philadelphia question here is to be
follow the graphics style detective
paradigm or do we consider it more like
the first argument of soften with use
where it has to be more propositional
well I think that a styled circle
through makes sense to me I don't know
if this follow being the region and
cause highlighting one having an option
that says who is to be started and how I
hate I hate that I mean I think that's
look okay several comments
first of all you think that this is a
pure graph and meshes and so on allowed
both they can deal with rappers and they
can deal with options that you can
control big chunks of things okay fair
enough yeah that sounds like a comment
here okay you think that triangle has a
visual graphical you know representation
but perpendicular doesn't I would argue
it does too because on the plot you
might draw one of those little
perpendicular II you know marks no they
both have a graphical representation but
the triangle is a region it's a set of
points in the plane they are
perpendicular is not a set of points
even if it might have some kind of label
like sync I understand it so in in
formal logic right there are these
there's you know when you start setting
up a language for a logic so to speak
there are typically these different
kinds of objects which are identified
there and I'm not sure yeah I'm not sure
how sensible it is to do that ultimately
but but let's let's come back okay so
the question personally I would say
mixing these makes sense to me with the
assumption that this is really that the
full form of this is exists at be a
triangle that right I mean is that is
that what you imagine that the something
like this right because we're circle
through with four points on the circle
you have to make that assumption I think
it's more like region Q than it is like
exists really yes uh the difference that
would say
exists FPA that doesn't change the fact
that triangle itself isn't a predicate
boolean right so really what we're
saying is we're trying to find an F P
and a such that all the graphics
primitives that show up are valid okay
so triangle that's not very strong with
circle through that's pretty strong
exists FP a region Q triangle with the
exception that you know that won't be
region Q because it's not concrete but
essentially well fair enough but I mean
yeah the issue is that is not a very
graphically that exists okay I mean this
is I get into these ridiculous
philosophical things so quickly I mean
the question of whether you know whether
existence can be painted so to speak by
which I mean I mean looks it reminds me
of sort of equals okay
AE equals B doesn't say false right it's
not a Q function you know it sort of
asserts it yeah but triangle what the
heck does triangle do but but I feel
like keeping in mind the audience for
this if we want to do this for high
school students
we cannot little this with existential
things of course of course of course but
the issue is what is the full
representation that we're imagining that
this has I think what you have there is
a fine way to conceptualize so my
question is there are predicates okay
the issue is sort of there's certain
aspects to this which are picture ball
and others that are not it would be nice
to I think it's den and it's some kind
of static okay
okay but did you understand my point
that there are there are some
I'm just thinking it's sort of a Monday
of the computer there are certain things
that can be visualized and others that
you know when you say triangle could
whoever's could somebody put themselves
on mute that whoever is has a weird
connection to this that now that noise
went away thank you um
let's ignore this this is this is this
evaluatable this this thing here
no this is not clear as it has the the
argument for conjectures so if I remove
the conjectures can I evaluate it that
we don't support the graphics primitives
or that the read yet so if you think I'm
so literary the read can I bet oh look
at that
yes you do that's magnificent that
that's the fake to output oh I was gonna
say I don't remember implementing this
at all you'd have to take that you have
that you have to take the braces officer
go through why didn't that work there's
no scene right you you didn't list all
of the okay you know I can if assumed
and it's a bit degenerate why is it so
generate sometimes when the scenes have
circles the the points in the clump so
let's figure out how to prevent that
happening right I mean in other words we
need to have good aesthetics for these
things make sense right what's the right
heuristic we may be discussing kata-kata
but there are may be some limits mister
cover and constraints almost yeah we
have okay this is really not and it's
it's kind of slow what's it doing how is
the constraint solution working so
basically we format geometric seen as a
constrained optimization problem where
the objective the value of the objective
function when we get a good seen should
be zero so then we throw that in the
fine minimum using IP ops and it looks
better than I would expect at finding
its
solving for coordinates for the points
and values for the quantities okay
they're basically so in the end I mean
so well Roger can you comment on that
I mean is this what is the form of
optimization that I mean is is is the I
need to see the underlying problems I'd
given that statement I don't know what
problems reasonable links with Danny
Nino walking up so nobody has a better
idea what to do okay okay alright so
then the only question is how to get
something where there's a better I mean
like this one is kind of kind of iffy
because it looks or one thing one could
imagine doing is that lets say that you
find if you run an optimization you find
something but clearly you know how you
can modify and iterate your way in that
scene to you know something that's more
aesthetic if something gets I've got a
different suggestion what what if there
was an additional constraint function
which was an aesthetic constraint
function that for example was like
repulsion but you do this well so there
there there are bits in the code that
try to guarantee that the the points
aren't directly on top of each other
although a lot of times they're very
near each other okay but so then you
need to change the parameter I mean
because you don't want them to right not
close to people right so you know just
one potential problem is we do allow the
user to put in if they want to
explicitly define where they want
certain points to be they can put in the
coordinates directly so if they if they
specify that the coordinates have to be
close to each other then that would come
into conflict with this we could doesn't
seem too bad but what I'm saying is you
should also have and this I don't know
controls speak to how this relates to
the graph drawing problem I mean like
this situation here is
not good right so you want something
weather where the cost function says I
don't like that when that line goes too
close to the point it's Charles with us
yes I'm here um can you comment on how
this relates to the graph drawing
problem well on top of my head I'm
essentially I see that maybe you know if
we get you know you get already one
solution from it you can essentially I
mean like we do in class essentially try
to I will not say we optimize it but you
know find a better solution by you know
using the initial solution less
constraint it's kind of what we do for
spring electrical type layout by the way
it is now the case that graphs can have
pinned vertices is that true and not yet
plan for twelve well one of these days
you're gonna tell me that's actually
done wonderful okay all right but but so
so you're saying that you have an
iterative technique that so Michael do
you understand that is Richard iterative
technique I don't think that's possible
here because you don't know whom you can
keep what do you mean by that
like to do this iteratively everything
is nicely fulfilled right now all of the
exit ones so it's not truly clear how to
start this this configuration to get a
better one
well what about so so there is a
derivative there's a presumably I see is
it is it the case okay okay this is a
geometry question which I should know
the answer to
given a configuration that solves these
constraints is there a connected surface
of configurations that also solve the
constraints sometimes yes sometimes no
what's that you might have Co dimension
zero one two three maybe it's a single
point maybe there's a three problem you
designed right and that's but that's a
problem of algebraic geometry now are we
in a position to actually compute that
for these you know I mean this is not a
rare geometry problem do we have from
all
fancy and recalibrate to composition if
the tide scared of ours yes not in the
time skaters exactly yes it's computable
so the answer is yes but you wouldn't
want to use it and there's no way okay
and the reason is because there's
algorithms even for something like this
get too slow I don't think we know I
mean if one looks more closer at it
usually reducing it to a very general
problem that has the advanced
has a complete solution it has the
advantage that you have a complete
solution but you won't be happy with it
won't be performant right no I
understand I understand so in principle
still Jakarta back to composition would
tell one the the complete space of
possible instances is our true statement
yes okay do you know even for a simple
case what it looks like I can get very
complicated very quickly okay yeah each
one of these points right this is is two
variables yes we have some ideas how to
him I do but I mean when I look at this
problem there's a zillion ways to reduce
the dimension I don't know if you you I
hope you pull some of those tricks yes
we do okay by the way we have a comment
on the live stream sander is asking how
does SolidWorks do this and saying that
they can immediately determine if it is
quotes fully defined I if there's only
one solution
really it seems surprising to me if you
scale up everything that's definitely
what infinitely many solutions if you if
you change the scale of your maybe
there's a dimensioning thing that
doesn't allow that Roger can you comment
on how CAD systems typically if you have
one solution it's it's acting much much
faster to do things then if you have
another free power meters running
exactly and
like if if there is a single
configuration that fulfills us this is
typically doable to get it pretty
quickly symbolically but if you have
five fleet symbolic power meters in the
zouzhen it's much harder - all right
let's keep going here no that's that's
one philosophical thing just to make
sure that we're all on the same page
so in this distinction between
separating the primitives form the
connectives we also inlining them all
together so the main reason we want to
inline is because it allows much more
faithfully to be produced and narrative
of how the exercises are stated in books
that's fine but I also think it's a good
idea the - you know I think that the
notion of being able to decorate these
things is useful yes to freely decorate
even perpendicular to freely decorate
that with some annotation that says oh I
want to use this kind of styling to
indicate my perpendicular thingy okay so
you would allow
equivalent of red comb online also to be
something coma perpendicular what no I'm
I'm saying yes I'm saying that but I
personally greatly prefer style - um -
the red comb or whatever but you can
support both forms but we should we
should have style someone on the live
stream is is asking what happens if we
add this is this going to work
see I put line in here so line is is the
party the system symbol that I want that
right if you're gonna have a list of
points you want line through line is
just okay fine well parallel okay yeah
this person is suggest okay well alright
let's just try the simpler case of just
line through Fe a right oh that makes
the picture worse right because it
writes that intersection point and we
were trying to get the e away from the
intersection right no it's not but it be
able to what's it doing here why did it
go off into lala land so if it doesn't
succeed it sometimes makes motive on try
right so basically the way spectacular
it worked right I mean it's damn slow
but it worked it's very slow so
basically the way it works with the fine
minimum call is it does a bunch of find
minimum calls until it finds a solution
where the objective value returned is
basically zero and if it returns
something that's too big then it does
another fine minimum call with a new
random seeding time because because the
convergence depends on the district with
this right so on these let's talk about
several different things so one thing is
fine minimum could end up in an
attractor Basin that just doesn't have a
a solution is that what you're saying
right and when it does that it it
abandons that fine minimum call and
that's a new one with a different
randomize so just so I understand I mean
in modern Iran that stuff where we're
basically also doing constrained
optimization other techniques
fundamentally are any of those
techniques relevant here I don't think
so because the majority of the is the
constraining yeah anytime you solve a
very specialized optimization problem
but say Traveling Salesman or something
you can develop techniques that are
particularly adapted to that problem and
so is the case for neural networks yeah
all right and the other thing that's
special about neural networks because
you basically you know fast
you know in modern iterative solver
unless it's very large-scale data I use
the second-order conditions but you
don't want to compute second derivatives
for your neural networks so they use
either no derivative so first two rivers
it's mostly first derivatives and they
use a ton of tricks for that particular
you know thing okay but but so just so I
understand here the I mean I'm trying to
understand what kind of acceleration
techniques we could imagine using mmm
for example is there any machine
learning play that we could make that
would allow us to guess I mean what's it
spending all its time doing is it
spending all its time iterating towards
a solution or what is it doing
yes okay I mean depending on how much
time you guys want to spend I mean you
can write your own optimizations over
from the ground up this is why would
that be useful because then you can
specialize this to this problem why is
that I mean why is this problem that
special just a bunch of polynomials I
don't know what the end problem looks
for not really like they could be poured
into a bunch of polynomials that might
be already non-trivial work because you
have
you have potentially trick function
because of anga constraints you have
square root because of lengths issues
right I see
so we've Zoey's IP up for this and which
is state of thought right in the state
of the art there are other so IP ops
currently in Wolfram language does not
accept precision specifications so this
is code that isn't activated now but we
have looked at using other optimization
methods that allow these precision
specifications okay we use IP op to give
it the original seeding and then have it
have those run once from that to try to
get a desired precision and those are
spectacularly slower than I got I see
that's not good okay by the way someone
on the live stream is asking why are the
arguments why are these arguments first
rather than lost I mean in other words
why does it look like this rather than
looking like solving integrate why does
it look like block rather than solving
the difference so they they were second
and then conjectures are optional and
conjectures won't last
yeah I don't think we can have them last
because of the optional conjectures well
we could do two other constructs like
graphics complex I agree I think there's
no better okay let's keep going here
well I wouldn't do it this quite this
way don't we have a different
highlighting mechanism how do you you
can have a highlighting wrapper a
highlighted wrapper in graphs and you
also have some kind of highlighted
vertices thing don't you there's no
vertices here I understand that I
understand so we need a different option
structure but I agree with the basic
idea that we should both be able to have
in line wrappers and overall options so
for instance you know one could
in here some pattern that says highlight
every well I'm not certain here but but
you know for example that's gonna be
styling for every point right like you
might want to say all points are styled
with you know gray instead of blue or
something right so you should be able to
have rappers in that first list of a.b
a.b efp you know if I want to highlight
the B point so those are implicitly
geometric point is that correct yes okay
because then again then I could define
my own label you know that's why I'm
sorry Lyle point any different from
triangle can I say the reason we
introduced geometric scene was to
eliminate the need for geometric point
everything it presently shows it hate it
okay it's a long name and B there was 2d
confusion about that the geometric point
is not the point because it's the think
inside the point so so your point here
is that but what if I want to have an
angle with a symbolic value no I'm sorry
an angle as symbolically you know the
angle alpha how do I do that are you
saying alpha is the measure of the angle
or you're naming the angle alpha what
did you click do how did he distinguish
between those two things the the measure
of the angle versus the name of the
angle I mean the name of the angle the
angle ABC for example we understand what
that is but that's referring to points
but I remember even in you know the sort
of manuscript II things probably not
from Euclid's time but you know that
there are you know it's there's an alpha
which I guess is the measure of the
angle yes
how do I do that I think you need the
three points to determine angle okay so
I say angle ABC equals equals alpha
right there actually if you scroll to
the very end there's some high school
geometry examples with very yeah all
very very end okay so what am I looking
at keep going I know I want to see what
else
what is this so these are these are not
implemented there there various other
suggestions for tissue there and there
not other subjects this is the fine
geometric seen instance that we've been
that that's what we've just been okay
let me look at fine geometric facts can
I run this hmm no these are the code
actually is implemented just not for the
structure of arguments we're kind of
going
we need to refactor things yeah so
that's a rather bizarre construct but
that's basically saying what is the
Euclidean distance AC yeah yeah right
that's a very bizarre way to ask that
question I mean in other words what
you're doing there is you're asking for
a proposition and just somehow you know
fishing out of the proposition of value
yeah as opposed to simply asking I mean
it seems like there what's that
just so we mean the second argument
should trust be Euclidean distance I
would think so just like you know the
question is okay the question is again
what is a fact it could a fact be I
don't think it's really that I think you
want to just say um it's something like
geometric evaluate or something because
what it is is it saying given the scene
what is the value of this thing cause
the question is you know is this angle
equal to this angle then the evaluation
is you know false for example so I mean
I think it's it's it's more like you
know geometric see and evaluate or
something I kind of disagree our
synthetic prover allows you to have a
pattern and it will prove all theorems
it can find that match that pattern okay
right now piece of functionality it
seems to me yeah let's do another day
the question is a IATA cleavers Ian and
don't think this is what you said this
is
more like a flavor of souls yes I agree
like this case all we're doing is
finding Euclidean distance but you could
put something a lot more general in
there just a general pattern to match a
general proposition about the scene it's
not necessarily just a measure fair
enough but I think that there is still a
you know geometric scene evaluate which
is useful and whether and that general
pattern that you want there is you want
to return all instances I mean in a
sense they want to say you know it's
more like a geometric seen cases okay so
geometric seen evaluate would take
something like this okay and would
return five okay just five okay just
five just evaluates the second it's a
little bit I D sorbet you yes okay right
and this here let's say let's say you
have a and then you would say
perpendicular you know blank comma blank
okay and that would return all the
statements about perpendiculars about
things that are perpendicular in the
scene am I making sense
right so what you have there for
geometric seen cases that's essentially
what I was going for with fine geometric
facts exactly right right
I mean I don't know whether the function
is right you know what the right
function name is um but I'm suggesting
that you know this is a useful thing
it's like evaluate that is this true in
this scene for example rather than
trying you know is this true having a
thing here and then having to come back
as a no list just say is it true you
know compute it given that scene I have
stream sander is asking why do you
actually need to give the variables here
why can it not be like Sol for example
where it assumes variables if where it
assumes that every every symbolic very
um our plan is to allow you to not
specify it and fill it in for you but
there are ambiguities that arise our
unit structure the vast majority of
times we can figure out which things are
points however since we're allowing
users to input specific coordinates if
they want to and maybe symbolic
coordinate so instead of putting in the
20 key right instead of putting in the
point P you can put in the list P sub X
comma P sub y there are just a couple
ambiguities so let's look at those let's
note that the one argument form of
source is not documented even if it were
turned up right right okay all right let
me just take a look here so what is this
um I don't understand what's this opens
it says that one there okay but that's
just so that's now saying but how do I
get the actual list of geometric okay I
run this I don't believe so
see if I did run it you would see the
output right below that geometric scene
of triangle
like right below where you have your
cursor oh I see so it's filling in into
the geometric scene it's leaving the
geometric scene there and it's filling
in so that's one of the big points that
the dramatic scene is this maker contain
over everything is nicely together right
so your point is that to have the
conjectures without or to have the
statements the propositions whatever
without the scene is kind of stupid
maybe not stupid but not ideal right you
have to know I would say it's it's
convenient to have them with this scene
because you can have it automatically
visualized but like Michael said early
that's a minor point to get the
conjectures out right
so we were thinking the geometric scene
blah blah blah of string pictures could
pull that argument the main thing that I
think is gonna be awkward is the naked
symbols here that you know somebody is
you have an X but somebody gave a value
to X those kinds of weird things they
make it popular because none of the
things is hold so it would still seep in
no no I understand okay okay so okay
fine oh my gosh okay let's have a quick
look through these things we're not
gonna get to all of this what am I
looking at here these are links to
webpages in the very beginning that
these books use a lot of symbols that
it's not clear if you've won them som
but it makes it very nice and convenient
and taught to fire them down their
scenes but they are kind of expressible
two things we have I don't care they've
been around since Euclid let's have them
I mean they're not going anywhere the
midpoint is is not it's a concept that
is a well understood concept it's you
know a word and mathematical language
that's been around for a couple of
thousand years I think we should have it
is there any objection to that I don't
think have
extra 20 such words lying around as a
problem because these words they're not
going anyplace
and even something like a triangle foot
I mean I I don't really see a problem in
having that it's a little weird but foot
of the altitude well I don't know what
the altitude is that's kind of weird so
they're ones of these that might need to
be tightened up a bit but I I think the
stead assume this particular orientation
of the Train yes it's kind of crazy no I
don't I don't think those you project a
on to the line beast right so if you
look at the argument they'd scroll down
examples right a is separated from Z and
see no this is a footed triangle so to
speak what the heck is it no it's a foot
it's a point oh I put it well wait a
minute wait a minute what is that the
point is I see the point is the
projection of that guy if if the thing
formed a triangle it is wait a minute I
don't know I think you trance thought
there was correct what's that I should
have I should have put in a graphic to
illustrate this but what you were just
saying I think you were you have the
idea it's a projection yeah and then
there's triangle altitude somewhere
which is just connects the vertex to the
triangle slit and it returns a line I
think we should have these things I
really don't think there's any harm in
having you know well this one I'm a
little down more Stephen you might want
to open there it says although it you
miss something what
but this oh oh my gosh okay
look some of these like quadrilateral
would have to be supported quite
generally but quite another one is so
often occurring I think we should know
fine but then Roger needs to support it
in the in the region system I don't
think that's okay clockwise I'm not at
all convinced about now we come into
more interesting
well some of these seem reasonable hmm
so you can have an equilateral Pentagon
and things as well presumably yes so I
mean there's some parts of speech issues
here with okay so I mean one question is
I mean if I were to look back at Euclid
would I find mutually tangent as a as a
as a predicate there probably not but
you would find it in like 18th century
geometry and so 200 years but not 2,000
years why is it not congruent and
similar something region congruent
region so there's a stronger notion of
congruence that only applies to polygons
this is at corresponding vertices get
mapped to each other okay and for
implementation purposes that's the only
one we could support and only in 2d oh
yeah I would expect region congruent or
whatever it to be called to just want
there to be a rigid motion that takes
one or the other okay I click on the
right side so angle would evaluate if
it's given explicit points yes yes don't
we already have a function that does
that with vector angle a triangle that's
a two-hour function right right this is
a three argument function okay whoever's
talking is only just a few bits are left
hello we've both water it's sorry mice
had a power fluctuation and trying them
um radiuses certainly that seems very
problematic to have a thing actually
called radius here I
that we can decorate these names to make
them more reasonable
no boy okay we're really running out of
time Hill will weigh over time but this
is I mean okay whoever the other meeting
we need another meeting yes this is
really cool though it's really cool all
the stuff but I mean what what their
angle measure oh my gosh okay let me
take a look at this
many polygon descriptors yeah I mean
maybe things like this I don't know I
mean another question is what the
natural language you know how are we
going to do it if you know presumably we
will have a natural language to this
stuff translator definitely we wanted we
have not started there any forms working
on it okay
it doesn't seem super duper difficult or
am I missing something
a lot of the problem is there's
implicitly diff there things that are
implied that aren't explicitly stated
yeah that's what we could deal with
algorithmically right I mean know what
we're trying to do is to generate one of
these geometric scene representations
and if there are things that are not
specified there that's what you'll find
geometric scene instance is supposed to
deal with what he means is that like
problem statements in books will leave
out necessary assumptions because like a
rigger like like absolutely necessary
example in this notebook control F for
things learn yeah controller
yeah orientation of polygons it's under
there what's it I said orientations of
polygons you write that top one though
fins are had a girth theorem so even in
let's see it says yeah
right so the right so this that the
conclusion is that circle or that square
that rectangle in the middle stq are
supposed to be a square but here it's
not because the square a b-prime c-prime
d-prime
it's supposed to have the same
orientation as the square ABCD but it's
not specified and if you look in
Wikipedia or math world it's not
specified you just you know looking at
the picture they have the same
orientation but it's never actually said
anywhere but if we wrote the proposition
that that thing PQ you know RS qrst
is a square that proposition could still
be validated given that scene is that
true that there exists a way to make
that a square well now that the the
statement is it's always a square right
well yeah the statement is it's always a
square and this is a counter example to
the normal statement where people leave
out that ABCD and a P prime C prime D
Prime have to be oriented the same way
so how else would one fill let in right
this is why we brought it up with right
processing natural language we're gonna
have to deal with the fact that a lot of
times I mean so somebody might give the
conditions for this thing they might put
them in and well from language and
they'll still get the wrong answer I
mean they're still okay so what is the
actual dynamic so somebody is doing a
geometry exercise and they're asked this
question and yeah I mean to a limited
amount basically if you have such
orientation potential orientation is you
trying both and giving messages right
okay so yeah one is the most common form
of dropped assumption yes there's
there's one other where there's we're
you list lines is parallel but they need
to be oriented the same
in the same direction as opposed to
anti-parallel and that's kind of a
dropped assumption to okay but those are
both combinatorially enumerable that's
right right and also both of those are
solved by the counterclockwise and
clockwise symbols that we proposed okay
I mean as a way to to DM disambiguate
them correctly but in terms of I see I
mean the in terms of user behavior if
there's a finite number of possibilities
and you can just enumerate them and look
at the different cases that's that's
okay um that would be pretty reasonable
okay I'm I'm really out of time here but
I'm enthusiastic to see different things
okay so that's a quadrilateral fine
what's your point here that those are
different numbers of angles is the
different right so they're the e-book
yeah these these you can evaluate if you
want this this one here is prayed
somewhat slow by that I still want to
understand how to speed these up I want
to understand what they're there's got
to be some way to you know effectively
interpolate these maybe I maybe I'm
crazy I mean maybe that they I mean it
seems like there's something very
special about the the surfaces that
correspond to the things you're trying
to optimize over here but maybe it's not
special I don't know I mean do you have
a characterization of what's special
about the the optimization problems that
you're doing here as opposed to generic
optimization problems they're not
they're not entirely polynomial I'm not
sure there's really anything so these
are so so yeah so what's the point of
these so they're just supposed to be
kind of unfortunate they're on top of
each other I mean the right longer in
triangles again that should be part of
the you know the drawing optimization
layer
this is really quite spectacular I mean
it's a very cool functionality I just
want to point out that these examples
all work because they're using an older
version of the same language right here
we're using the geometric point it works
both ways
Johnson's theorem is pretty slow it has
a bunch of very interconnected circles
some of these advanced geometry ones do
take a while because the more
complicated the seam is and the more
there's a limit so this particular thing
has not broken the proposition from the
it just is this because it's an older
version yeah this lesser version so
English is sitting along with the other
stuff right so here these are just the
hypotheses and yeah that's actually an
accurate picture well cool okay
Napoleon's doing yeah I feel like
Napoleon didn't actually do this himself
are you sure this is another one that
output on this particular theorem well
right so you see a lot of extra lines
because it involves centroids and
currently for triangles the centroid
if you drop these altitudes they all
meet in the centroid so I draw the lines
but now I look at it it's a little it's
a little confusing to actually draw just
make them dotted lines or something yeah
all right spectacular functionality guys
clearly we need to have a further
discussion about it but I think there's
all you're fine with geometric scene had
first argument points yes style of
something that's what I'm fine with and
I'm also fine with the idea of
introducing you know anything Euclid did
is okay 200 years ago it's still okay
you know any of those kinds of geometric
predicates seem fine to me some of them
may need a little bit more detailed
names
a new stuff even if from Arnold from ten
years ago no like what he introduced a
couple generic region sent us lots of
region centers that's probably a string
name for the region centers and then you
know you can go to town and put in any
region seventy you want
we are eighty is thinking on putting the
15,000 filings and sandals in this way
also adding 15,000 symbols that's
exactly what do you mean 15,000
triangles there's that right here's rap
there's a website where with one guy
compiles all there are I'm sure there's
a lot of those that have put up jobs
I cannot imagine there 15,000 sensibly
named ones
why would somebody well I won't even go
there publish or perish there okay fair
enough
this is really cool functionality very
nice stuff look forward to seeing more
of it okay okay thanks guys and bye to
everybody on the livestream thank you
for your participation